uh i've spent quite some hours already
i think all of you on youtube searching
for a thing how does it work
and usually pi data movies are quite
good to to get a first feel for
everything and
i'm really uh i hope that today i will
inspire you to to do the same thing
so
yeah what we're going to talk about is
data pipelines
i'll give a quick introduction about
myself
then we'll talk about data pipelines i
have some five tips basically that i
want to share
and then
part of those tips are delta lake and
then i'll go into a demo so so
yeah fingers crossed that everything
works out
and and then of course there's time for
some questions
and i have to do it low key because it's
not working so
we'll do it like this so
who am i my name is kier jonger i'm a
data engineer data scientist at pippel
basically i started out as an industrial
engineer 10 years ago i graduated in
2012
and at that point i've i've never heard
of data engineer or data scientist i i i
don't know how it's for you guys but but
at that point it was all fairly new
and basically yeah throughout my yeah in
those years i i moved into that position
without calling it that and then in the
end i realized yeah this is really the
name that covers it
um
and yeah right now i'm basically with
people i'm doing the people pipelines
and that's basically projects we do with
data pipelines so at different companies
yeah we develop
pipelines and that can be small
pipelines big
yeah
whatever is needed to get the job done
basically
um
and yeah it's just a very short note on
people people small company
located here in itover we actually have
a new office
and we're doing uh yeah data engineering
data science
yeah as a broad topic
so that's that's about people
data pipelines who of you has heard of
the term data pipelines
i guess everyone currently now has it
can can you tell me something about data
pipelines what you think of if that
infrastructure infrastructure yeah
definitely it has an infrastructure part
to it
um could you could you tell me something
what
what metadata yeah definitely definitely
uh you
moving data from a to b yeah yeah that's
my abcde yeah yeah yeah good good you
picked it up very smart
uh yeah so um you can do it once
yeah so i just wrote down some some some
things that for me make up a data
pipeline because there's a lot of talk
there are a lot of different versions
basically you can call anything a data
pipeline but for me it feels like you're
moving data from one location to the
other the usually you start with
something and you end up with something
else
often you have like multiple inputs that
together make something new which is
which is highly valuable more valuable
than the inputs themselves
you transform data
data quality is a big topic that we're
actually realizing now
for some time it was a bit to the back
as long as you get more data
things will work out
but i think we're learning now that that
data quality is really important and and
you you yeah sometimes more data will
not solve your problem you need better
data
data versioning is a big one so so
um yeah as a data scientist you're
highly
uh
yeah relying on history you need to know
what the data was like
an hour ago a day ago a week ago because
otherwise if you're just using the data
as it is now you
it's very easy to have data leakage
things that that
you know now and then if you start
predicting stuff with things you know
now yeah it's of course very easy to to
do that so data versioning is important
and um yeah scheduling
i think the we all agree a pipeline
usually you build it for more than once
and you're not going to build a pipeline
to do it once and then throw the whole
thing away
so um well what's what what does it look
like then as a whole yeah so so this is
what i took from from delta lake i'll
talk a bit more about it
basically any any sort of of data uh
data platform data lake will have
certain sections uh in this case they're
calling it bronze silver gold but it
might be staging it might be raw landing
zone whatever
there are a lot of terms but we all
agree you have to start with the raw
data you're going to
move it
you're going to increase the quality of
the data you're going to you're going to
do whatever you need to to get the
information out of it that you need
and then finally um
yeah what we call gold in this model
this is the data set that you're giving
to a different team in this case it will
be the data science team
most often but it can be reporting it
could be a simple excel list just
helping a team to know which clients are
problematic or
it can be anything
so
yeah
so
i could talk hours about that previous
uh overview yeah uh go into all the
nitty-gritty details and uh and talking
about all the ways set up
but my talk was like how can we set up
data pipelines for data scientists and
for me
in reality you have a small team you
have limited time and you do want to get
some of these benefits but you do not
have the resources or you don't know if
you're gonna need the resources to
actually build this full on data
platform with all whistles and bells
attached to it
so what i'm gonna try to show you is a
bit like how can we set it up in a way
that for a relatively small project
you're still gonna get into
yeah that some of the benefits of that
full model
um but actually using it for yeah in a
limited time setting so
so data pipelines for data scientists
yeah
so uh yeah what do i mean by that so so
you're a data scientist you are working
at a project
well of course you're gonna receive data
in csv format yeah you're not gonna
get it in a nicely uh format that has
schemas attached to it or anything
you're gonna start analyzing the data
and we've had a lot of talks looking
into the how do you do that all these
packages this morning so
and you want to work towards that first
model to know is there actually
something happening
is there actually value in in my model
then
there's a reasonable amount of data
you're busy for one week and at that
point someone's gonna say well actually
we just gave you part of the data so so
we're gonna give you more
and yeah now you're stuck with with two
csvs that that that are
a little bit different
so i'm gonna show you how
we might organize this process to to
to smooth it out
then
um yeah so first five tips in general
and then i'll go into the specifics so
first of all i think it's really
important to have a clear split when you
start this this assignment
on what's data engineering and what's
data science
both of them have pipelines both of them
have things that that
will help you select columns from a
database
etc
so so try to put the data processing in
a data engineering pipeline and
everything else with model fit and and
and
normalizing stuff etc do that in your
machine learning pipeline but yeah be be
conscious on the decision in which part
you're going to do stuff
the the easier the data engineering
pipeline it's quite easy to change some
logic and to remove columns etc
in the in the data science pipeline so
let's say you're using cycle learn to
test a pipelines module where where you
can actually
select columns and do a whole lot of
things
if you do it in that part it will mean
that whatever model you choose you still
need to put in all the data because it
expects the same input data yeah
whatever you're then doing with it
so
yeah be conscious about it and and and
try to put the data part in the data
engineering pipeline and do not mix them
up
you know
then
notebooks i think yeah that could be a
whole talk as well
i think yeah who of you is working with
notebooks
yeah
pretty much
i think 78
well a lot of the tools that you use
especially the cloud-based ones they're
all around notebooks and
anub a notebook is very easy the first
hour
but usually within a day within a week
you mess it up you know it's very easy
to to
switch cells etc
so
force yourself to have simple notebooks
so the flow should always be from top to
bottom i think most of us know that
but also
with the data engineering part
you usually have splits there's like
this for for this model i'm only
interested in clients in the
netherlands or or i'm only interested in
this subgroup
and then you do certain steps only to
that subgroup
use different notebooks for that so
and then use either an orchestration
tool like apache airflow or azure data
factory
but if you want to do it a little bit
low level just use another notebook
which is very easy i just
if and then you just have python
function need to run you just run this
other notebook so in that way you can
you can create complex flows which which
are still fairly easy to maintain each
each notebook in itself is just a
regular
yeah linear flow of steps
then naming
this is also such a topic that that
that can
that can take quite some time
just start out have a sit through take
one hour and just decide
on
how i'm going to name columns which am i
doing all caps or lower
i'm going to name the files are we using
an integer for example first notebook
second no book third notebook you know
sit together it doesn't have to be
really complicated but take the time to
decide it and then make sure you follow
through of course
with these things
um
then
very important
all data needs to have a source
so
before you start any project and you use
any data set
make sure you know
who is actually
owning that data set yeah where is it
coming from
it's really trivial
but it actually isn't because i think
there are a lot of companies where data
just lives somewhere
and there's an i.t person who's who's
managing the database or the application
but
they don't well they do know what's in
there but they don't know what it means
so
you you need to know before you start
using stuff
who is owning it and where can i go with
questions because they will arise
and it wouldn't be the first time that
you know that you were actually looking
at a subset instead of the whole set for
example which which
can take some time
for external data the same principle
holds
but it's more
like can we trust this party um do they
have
support um
and what's what's their updating
frequency is it the source or is it do
they actually use their own data logic
to to fill in the gaps etc
all sorts of questions you need to ask
yourself before you start using the
yeah an external data source june
yeah
and then uh finally and and this is
where where i i will move a bit further
prepare for changes
because um i've i've often started the
project that's one-off or that's
temporary and then it's never one-off
and it's never temporary i think
most of you will recognize it at least
once
so
that's why i want to give away like like
with data pipelines as well
you are going to run them more often so
build them that way they don't need to
be
highly complex
but they need to be runnable
which means that you can just run the
notebook it'll produce a data set you
re-run it it will produce the same data
set yeah
or it will do nothing even better
as long as you don't have any new data
and reproducible so
if you move to a different machine if
you have a different laptop etc
it should work the same way it shouldn't
mess up
anything
so that brings me to delta lake which is
who have you has heard of delta lake
just okay okay fairly number
well actually
yeah
this is i think the main focus of today
so
they're there
a few years ago basically data bricks
which is which is
the
developer of spark basically the
original developer
they introduced a new data format which
is which is called delta
and what it builds on is
parquet which is
which is i think most of you probably
have seen parquet once or twice which is
a a columnar data store which compresses
data and has schema on read which is
which are very important characteristics
because
yeah it helps
keep the data consistently
and then they developed this delta
format which is basically a layer on top
of these parquet files
so
let me i'll explain
very briefly
how it works so there's this
data file which is in this case
file1.parquet
that contains the actual data so if for
people not familiar with part k you can
compare it to a csv
only it has schema information attached
and some some more
interesting features
and then it adds a log
that basically is saying every iteration
which files are
part of the current version
so let's say i have a table i update
something which means a new parquet file
then there will be a corresponding json
saying and now you should use these
parquet files
and with every update it keeps track of
which files changed why did they change
and um yeah which files are current
what that means i will show in in the
demo
well it's it's it's it's made by
databricks originally um so that's yeah
databricks is is a closed
uh spark implementation
but they open sourced it so so actually
the delta format itself as well as the
libraries to read it are open sourced
and there are there's even a standalone
reader available that that allows you to
use it without spark
so i will show you in the demo also how
to read it without having the spark
the standalone data writer so creating
these files is currently only possible
through spark
but there is this
writer coming this year which would then
basically allow you to do everything i
show in the demo with purely python
without using any spark
and power bi for example has also a
reader so like a csv you can
put it on your machine and power bi will
already know how to read these logs and
give you all of the benefits of delta
so that brings me to demo time
i was originally intending to do it here
myself but there are some technical
difficulties that my laptop has to be
over there
so you have to think we're now
everywhere
so
if you could run the first files
so it's a it's a demo and even on a
distance so so i'm pretty
happy if this goes goes smooth
so basically well what i said there
delta it's it's made by databricks it
currently depends still on spark to to
create files so so i can't give this
demo without
instantiating a local pie spark so this
notebook is open source it's just the
open source version of pi spark and each
one of you can download it and work with
it
so
we create a spark instance and then
going down
we're going to read in
some wine data which you can see over
here
and basically
yeah i'm showing the schema so it's a
wine review data set so there are wines
there are reviewers there are points
that make up a review
so yeah we want to do date science yeah
so
let's say we want to predict
which wines are going to get positive
reviews and which ones are going to take
negative reviews
and now i'm focusing of course on the
data part
so we we read in the data and you can
see there are points price yeah nothing
uh nothing special about that
now we're going to create
we're going to read in the data and then
the first thing that i would recommend
to everyone
if you're using this way of reading in
data
use a read stream to to stream the data
in
i think with streaming maybe
some people will think like that's
really difficult yeah getting things
real time etc but that's not what we're
doing here
we're actually um
yeah if you run the next cell as well
so we're reading in the csv
and then where um
yeah the screen is pointing everywhere
but um the important thing is is trigger
once so
it's just reading the stream but it's
only doing it once
and the the benefit is that you get sort
of a hybrid version it's it's not actual
streaming where you're constantly
asking for new records and it's it keeps
on running but you're just doing it once
so it's actually a badge
it's just doing a one-time
load of the data
with and that's the big win if you do it
like this with a checkpoint location
meaning that it keeps track of the files
it read
so
if you do if you rerun this now
you will actually see it will not
process anything because it knows oh i
already saw this file
so i don't need to do anything so this
makes it runnable reproducible and it
will prevent you from waiting
if there's no update it will actually
give you zero records and of course that
will take
almost no time to to execute
so if we move on
we can
yeah
and then basically i'm from this part if
you i'm reading in the delta file and
you can see that it loaded these 180 000
reviews
then
can you move your head a bit and i know
the time that i have left to uh yeah
perfect okay cool
so yeah i don't want to keep you off the
drinks i said that's important as well
because otherwise uh yeah
so um yeah looking at this
spark you can see i loaded the table and
now this is just some simple
command prompt lines to move in a new
file what i mentioned
what happens
there's new data yeah it's the same
table but it's new data
in this case we get a new file which
only contains new records
because we've used this format we can
just rerun this is the same code as
above we can just rerun this the
these cells
and it will just add these
1000 records without having to change
any code or
looking at that so you could trigger
this job you can run it on your laptop
and it will just automatically add any
records that you need
and then yeah you can show that it's
yeah yeah it added the 1000 lines
to your table
yeah
you can move on
yeah
so
now there's this thing that
if you look closely you see that we
actually stored it as a delta table so
what i mentioned the data is in parquet
format so it's just regular per k files
but we have this added feature where if
you run these two steps you can see that
there's
a history attached to this table so
that's this is actually just reading the
json files in the log
what you can see is there's now a
version zero and a version one
and there's some additional information
on when it was created etc etc and that
means you can read this table without
changing the path without changing any
settings with an additional option of
saying give me the data set as it was
with the version number
or with the timestamp you can just say
give me the data as it was last friday
and it will automatically know which
parquet files to use to give you that
exact state of the data
then of course the the
yeah so you can already
yeah run this so
of course this is the ideal situation
you get a file with only new data that's
that's
that's nice so we can update
in reality i've i've had loads of times
where it's not possible to get just the
new data you just get a full table again
and again because there's no incremental
load process involved yet
in that case you can create a merge
function
which basically
says the only important bit to remember
is you need to know what identifies a
review that we've already seen so in
this case
there's the taster and there's the title
which is the actual wine that it's
reading
so if the taster is the same and the
wine's the same
then of course the review is the same
and if something changed in that part so
let's say that in this case the the
score was incorrectly calculated for
some reason
we want to update this row we want to
remove the old one and just insert the
new line
so
using this merge function in combination
with
this
stream query
will ensure that it's just updating
these 100 lines in the same code
so um yeah
this is what's called update insert so
an upsert basically in
in data engineering
and
yeah again it's the same code
and it will mean that you can just rerun
this every time for both the new
situation as well as
i don't know where that's coming from
yeah
so um uh yeah interesting
um yeah you can run it yeah and then you
will see that
[Music]
you update this
and then the same thing happens there's
this history
attached to it we'll have an additional
version where these hundred lines are
different
and because we have this we can also
very easily if you move down a bit
takes some we have to wait until the
job's done so
that we have to move two up
yeah let's run the stream query progress
so if that is
if that is long then it means the job
has finished now it has to go through
all the data
i've done no indexing or any performance
tweak so it has to very stupidly go
through every line and check whether
it's updated so you can rerun the 28
yuan
and i would expect
yeah so now there's this actual
version two so that's the third version
with other information yeah it's not
very readable but
you can actually see in the log
why this version was created with the
update statement etc so it's a different
sort of change between the versions than
the previous one
and then using this format using the
version as off i'll show you you can
just load the old data new data
same path same code you just add the
version number and you can compare
yeah what changed give me the lines that
are different
and then move
move from there
so if you move down a bit
yeah
yeah so in this case
i'm showing one of the wines which
actually went from 88 to 35. so in the
same notebook from the same data source
i read those two versions i compare them
etc
all in very i think readable codes
to to create
then i mentioned there's also the code
above is using spark as a part of the
of the
package this one is actually not using
spark so you can that's the difference
between delta and delta lake the naming
is of course confusing
but yeah knowing this you can just have
a python you can pip install delta lake
and you can read these files and have
all of the
features i showed above as well like the
version number the time stamping etc
so that concludes my demo
yeah
so
uh yeah what i've shown you um yeah so
delta i think it's a very
it's yeah it's now the point where it's
pretty easy to use
um
it it
gives you an option to load data that's
that's coming in with multiple files at
different times and as well as giving
you the option to do
very easily if you get full loads every
day to do an update where your table's
not exploding with other stuff
and yeah you can easily query across
these versions so you also for a machine
learning perspective
you can just say
give me the version that i used last
week to train this model
you give it a timestamp so you don't
even need to remember which version it
was
and uh yeah you can train the new model
on the old data to know whether the the
performance increases based on the data
or on your
model
then yeah there are of course some
limitations so so i try to cover them a
bit this is really like a startup phase
of your project
there are limitations of the laptop that
i use of course in this example or your
vm in this
case and i think the most important
thing you need to consider is that all
data versions the way i showed it to you
right now are stored on your
disk yeah so basically you're
duplicating
there are if you start partitioning that
there are a lot of ways to prevent this
or to prevent it as much as possible
but of course that takes more time and
it makes it more complex so so i think
in the beginning where you have limited
data let's say a few gigabytes it's it's
not that difficult to have 10 versions
of that on your machine
so
it's it's something you need to keep
track of
if you start using far bigger bigger
data sets of course you need to go to a
cluster version to to to scale according
to the data you need
this code will run also exactly on a
data bricks or in azure synapse you
don't need to change anything it's the
same
same code
and finally
yeah if you really get into big data
there are of course performance issues
etc and you need to start looking at
that well indexing all of these things
come up
that that you need to consider
so that's basically the conclusion of my
of my talk about data pipelines i i hope
i inspired you to
to start looking at this stuff i think
it's really helpful and and
yeah we're at a stage where these files
will will be able to be shared across
teams using different tools
etc
so i think in a few years i hope that
everyone is is working in this way and
yeah using it to
to
version the data basically without too
much too much hassle
then
to conclude
we're also doing bits of help so i work
at pipple
we just started bits of help which is
basically
an organization that that helps data
scientists data analysts data engineers
who want to do something good who want
to do something for the society to spend
some of their time on projects like the
ocean cleanup like the red cross etc
so
if you're interested in these things you
feel like i want to contribute something
to something else than just
the the commercial model so to speak
then go to this website
yeah it just started and there are quite
some projects that that
yeah that that are really data sciencey
and that are uh yeah
also with an impact basically
so um yeah that concludes my talk thank
you for listening